うん
ame
bejean
お母さん
北高校に行かないからね
と
中学3年の息子の突然の宣言でした
a
本気なの
と思わず聞いてしまいました
考えてみると方本気なのかどうかを私は知らなかった理由
子育て間違ったのかなとかいろんなことを思いました
う彼は
その道を選んで
自分が好きなことをしていきたいんだ
と言っています
その彼はストリートダンスという大好きな道を選んで
東京で仕事をしながらダンスを続けていました
ん
いろいろなダンスのショーとたよと言ってインターネットで配信される画像を見せて
くれました
を頑張ってるじゃない
と思いながら
楽しく見守っていこうと思っていたんです
すると
また胸は突然に帰ってきました
いつも彼は突然なんですが
鹿児島の
子供や大人たちにダンスってすっごく楽しいんだよ
楽しむことが男子なんだよっていうことを教えたいと言って
あれは鹿児島に帰ってきました
夢をキラキラさせて目で今を語る息子か会の活動を応援しようっ
もう一度
ともに体験を積み重ねていきたいなというふうに思いました
まもなく1000人規模のだーーする公演をすることになりました
会場が広いです
席はいっぱいあります
誰か強い招待できるんじゃないかなっていうふうに考えた時にふっと浮かんだのが
以前テレビで放映されていた
養護施設の子どもたちの様子でした
あの子たちを招待してみようというふうに思ったんです
そして私は市役所に行ってどこに施設があるのかも知らないので
全部教えてもらい各施設に入ってお電話をしたり
プライヤーを持って行ったりしてそこの子どもたちを招待しました
後日
公演を見に来てくれた子供たちが
作文をくれました
夢のようだった
こんなのを見れるなんて思ってもいなかった
あんな風にダンスを踊ってみたい
あんな風に歌ってみたい
あんな風にギターを弾いてみたいなどたくさんの
作文をもらいました
私のやることでこんな風に喜んでくれるんだ
ということを思ったときそのことをきっかけに
息子は養護施設にダンスレッスンに行くようになりました
それから3年の家が建ちました
3年間ずーっとダンスレッスンを受けてくれた子供たちが
とても上手にダンスを踊れるようになったので息子たちとダンスのレッスン生たちと
一緒に大きなイベントに出るようになりました
たくさんのお祭りにも出るようになりました
そこへ行く途中車の中やお弁当を食べながらの楽しい会話
そこで私はいろんなことに気がつきました
中学生は僕らめやに行った事が無いんですって言って一緒にラーメン屋さんにキラキラ
したミュウしてあの来てくれたことや
サツマイモに代わってあるんですねっていう高校生の女の子
そんな子供たちといろんなやりとりをしていたら
何らかの理由で親御さんと暮らすことができない子供たちだからこそ
たくさんの大人や子供達との何げない体験が
実は彼らにとってとても素晴らしい体験であるということに気づかされました
子ども達の目をキラキラさせてあげるような素敵な体験がもっとたくさんできるような
気がして
より風道を広げようと思い npo 法人を立ち上げました
ダンスのワークショップを開催してたくさんの子供たちと一緒にぐるぐるを撮ってみて
くれたり
紙ヒコーキを6種類もれる
博士がいてその彼に紙飛行機よりを習ってみんなでとばしゃいっこをしました
またドラムサークル
今日のスピーカーでらっしゃるもいたさんに来てもらってなぜドラムをたくさん並べて
そこでドラムに音によるコミュニケーションを取らせてもらったり
交換を入れて
読み聞かせの会を開かせてもらったり
これも交換を入和楽器ノートを聞かせてあげたいということで
三味線や太鼓を持ってきてくれて
兵六物語を語ってくれた
ダンスの発表会に
ダースを習っている子は全共演しましたそして見に来てもらう子たちはたくさん見に来
てもらって
楽しい発表会を
やりました
こそ凧どす子どもたちのキラキラした体験は大人方も変えてくれるではないかという
ことに気がつきました
子育て世代だけではなく
子どもたちをまだ持っていない若者たちも
またことだけは終わったけど
なんかもゆとりがあって
他にもたくさんの子供たちと一緒に会ってみたいなというお父さんやお母さんたちも
地域や npo などの活動を通じて子どもとのキラキラ体験を集めることができます
子どもと大人が共に育ちあうって
素敵な社会ではないでしょうか
ありがとうございます